hey guys I'm Ryan right I'm Jerry today
we're checking out the trailer for the
reunion of Kevin Hart and ice cube
boy they're riding along again in right
along to surprise January hit now
they're back with a sequel it's a huge
hit yeah what do you mean it's part two
never well it could have been just a
moderate hit you can know it was a huge
hit all right billions of dollars at the
box billion dollars worldwide
highest-grossing movie of all time
oh god what we need - first time at that
we got a crazy no way you want to go and
do that
[Music]
some cars but I don't see no muscle your
partner is marrying your sister good top
sex cop is the best wedding planner in
Atlanta so what you're going to do Pope
in Miami you need to get me something on
this guy two days tops so get a team
together to fix this make sure you're
back in time to make me mrs. black
hammer
oh they were in my panty drawer not
yours you gonna go by Miami PD let them
know me here Oh soft tissue manipulation
detective pay it's not the first shaking
hear that this Pope is might be
contraband through the port you're gonna
help me get some hard evidence or how do
we get an undetected
no prints ad will see them in timber
plus my two servings I'm not just
serving Thank You ina respect I cannot
feel my face the brothers-in-law just
got to town you say that again someone
little too much of the yeah you know it
looks funny to me I mean the first one
was like a decent comedy and Kevin Hart
really made me laugh didn't get great
reviews but [ __ ] it was still funny yeah
it's so fun I mean like I feel like
Kevin Hart's one of those guys worth
like even if he's not in a very good
movie he's still gonna make you laugh
yeah I just thought to get hard about a
week ago and that's another one that
didn't get great feedback from critics
but he made me laugh a lot do you get
hard oh I got hard my jerked off to
Kevin Hart I mean feel probably the same
way about this as I did about right
along I mean they're heightening it up
and it looks they obviously got a bigger
budget they got Benjamin Bratt in there
and they have that Olivia Munn too and
Tyrese Gibson Reese and I'm happy to see
Ken's young playing on the way in upper
ones yeah just just kind of playing what
I hope is just a fun supporting
character yeah I like how they're kind
of taking elements of like Michael Bay
films meets especially the Miami shots
and everything oh yeah I mean you know
it seems like that's one of the things
you do in any I have a cop franchise
you're gonna go to Miami at some point
and also I in there turning it into a
team this time kind of taking a little
bit of bits from Fast Five and turning
into right along weird serious to take
to start taking those notes on but yeah
sure why not if we're gonna continue
this why not but it looks fun and I like
where they're taking it it's not like a
deep film or something you just go there
for laughing to watch Kevin Hart and ice
cube banter and do it well it's a
January comedy all I can hope for is
that it will be enjoyable I love it when
he sat on the fan yeah yeah I mean that
was a really well directed bit right
yeah that's like you know he's coming
just the ramp-up in physics anyway guys
thanks for tuning in if you're new to
the channel you can subscribe to the
real rejects you can check out reason
tsageri on this channel also dank ass
Stubbs and you can follow us on Facebook
Instagram Twitter vine and periscope a
Connor Sykes whoo hey guys could have a
shout-out from England
I'm not going to England to give you a
shout-out England leads you always crack
me up and I love the channel keep up the
great work
hello Corner Sykes you a good lad you're
a good lad you might be a good cop with
tight you're going way too hard
sweet more chimney is the e sound so
exists no with the British accent all
day Borah get care is from rock movies
knock snatch in their walks talking to
smut and bells the corner you a good
[ __ ] you know I seem like you're
slipping into a straw in there that's
not really me you just did well I'll be
that wasn't Australian we could be New
Zealand its Chinese you idiot yes
Chinese holy did your Chinese axe I just
did my Chinese trying to give a
shout-out to Conor not China
I saw him I sorry me were you tie your
oh sorry your stereotypes down